all right can it finally be accepted
reality that this kind of crap is
written by
AI I mean is it
[Music]
not had to say crap at the beginning of
this video for YouTube monetization
purposes the AI bot really hates it when
you swear in the first few seconds of
your video that said we're more than a
few seconds in now so what the man
so in this time of MCU phase four and
five otherwise known as post end game
MCU DLC we now have the Marvels Captain
Marvel Monica Rambo and Miss Marvel
Kamala Khan they all team up and
something happens to where when one uses
their powers they'll swap with the other
one and I got to say when I saw the
first trailer for the Marvels which
heavily concentrated on that mechanic I
was like that could be fun I don't know
that that mechanic had to be some super
big budget MCU monstrosity I mean you
could have had an indie film with that
premise and that would have been fun
that would have been fine everything
everywhere swapping around working title
but you get what I mean that simple
premise of fun just feels like it's in
something that's overproduced and
inflated then when I saw the second
trailer that just looked like generic
big budget MCU space adventure nonsense
I was like there it is I got to give
props and credit where credits do Iman
volan who plays Kamala Khan Miss Marvel
I thought she was great in fact she was
the screen presence in the entire film
I've not seen Miss Marvel so this is my
introduction to her but I have heard
she's great in Miss Marvel and I do get
it after see in this she has an
endearing quality to her it might
actually be real life bleeding over onto
the screen a fan girl who's now playing
in the sandbox she once dreamed about
playing in it works she was actually the
heart of the movie there's a whole
Captain Marvel Monica Rambo connection
that's supposed to be heartfelt it I
mean it was there you're going to hear
me say that a lot in here I feel well
that was
there guess we should talk about that
Carol danver's Monica Rambo they have
this connection of the past and there
are times you feel like oh hey that it's
it's kind of getting there maybe it does
more than I'm giving it credit here but
it's really hard for those emotional
moments to come through when the movie
that's built around it is crap actually
to be fair I thought there was a really
good scene dealing with Monica Rambo's
emotional past when they all put on the
demolition men head pieces I thought
that was good the Monica Rambo Carol
Danver Dynamic landed a lot better than
the Carol Danver villain Dynamic Monica
Rambo for the most part I was like what
is it you do here such a bummer because
during and after wand Division I was
interested as to where they were going
to take that character by the end her
entire character was relegated to just
being a McGuffin but all in all I saw
Captain Marvel I saw W division I've
never seen Miss Marvel and Miss Marvel I
thought was the best character of The
Three As for the villain in this movie
darb Ben don't know much about the
character from the comic books looked up
a little bit before he started doing the
review didn't do a big deep dive or
anything but from what I read it sounds
like it would have been really easy to
take this new villain just turn this new
character into Dollar Store roning the
accuser or
something and that's exactly what they
did the villain in this movie is the
absolute worst and that's in the MCU
that's saying something the kind of
impressive where they had to try to
it up this badly feel like the
conversation was no deeper than we want
Ronin the accuser back but I've been
told he's been dead in the MCU for years
now plus character development just
takes up screen time we want to pull
this baby back to under two hours hear
me out on this one like Ronin pretty
much
him only a woman this time cuz that's
all the development you need genius
comes to brilliant by the way you see
that South Park episode oh God
don't get me started how wrong can you
get it and I feel like I should clarify
given the mechanics of the MCU
Multiverse this isn't supposed to be a
female variant of ronin like Sylvia's
toi this is just a new villain the
villain and the dynamic between Carol
Dan and villain on paper probably
sounded great like in Concept in my mind
I could just see a layout where it's
like yeah that sounds awesome in
execution doesn't feel like there is any
Dynamic the character development's not
there we're being told this we're being
told that all the while it just feels
like baddy doing baddy things and they
got to stop bad there
ah spoilers I can't do it here I can't
talk about it here if I give two
enough to do a spoiler Talk video I'll
do that you feel like there's a whole
movie of setup before this movie that
you should have watched that never
happened oh God is that just set up for
a prequel series on Disney
plus I wouldn't doubt it the villain
even has ronan's Hammer but after Ronin
put the Power Stone in it so the Power
Stone made it really powerful it's like
this villain has that version of The
Hammer with the Power Stone but without
a power Stone I was like is there a
power Stone out there I'm not aware of
granny she does have a magical Relic
device that seems to be acting through
the hammer but is that is that is that
just what happens with the hammer any
magical Relic or device that acts
through the hammer just acts One Way
anything going through the hammer just
acts like the purple infinity stone it
doesn't come across as a continuity
thing comes across as a we don't know
how to do anything new or different
thing so that covers the characters is
that it wait there's more the CGI in the
movie there's a lot going on in the
action sequences whether it's a lot of
CGI or characters swapping places
because they're using their powers which
is kind of intermittent there were
definitely moments where I was like the
character used your power and she didn't
Swap and why didn't she swap sometimes a
little bit of power will make them swap
sometimes they need to use more Powers
but they don't always Swap and it never
explains why not like we live in what's
known as the digital age in which all
you have to worry about is the internet
picking apart your inconsistency so
sometimes the action sequences just look
like CGI but when you had a still moment
nothing distracting you you got to zero
in on the CGI oh yeah that was
noticeable there are a couple of dumb
ass side quests not only does this
movie generally feel like a tech demo
for gameplay mechanics how you swap
places with other characters gameplay
mechanic you know how every Sandbox game
has that mission where you're like this
is Goofy this is some ridiculous
but every game gets W this isn't a game
but it still gives us one it's
weird actually no there's two there are
there are two side quests that are
absolute ridiculous I'll be
vague but I'll talk about them here
there's this one planet they go to in
which people just sing to talk to people
if you just talk to them they can't
understand you you have to sing to them
I was like this would be fine in an
episode of DuckTales or something
Launchpad McQuack flies Scrooge McDuck
Hy dewy and Louie to this other land
where people sing when they talk at the
very least speak Walla Wala bing bang
Disney Afternoon baby in an MCU movie it
just felt like someone trying to
recapture that ta kaai Titi energy but
Thor loving Thunder ta a white TD energy
it was ridiculous another one
keeping this one vague it has to do with
cats and it's dumb as too and these
two comedy bits just feel out of place
in this movie makes the movie feel
totally inconsistent but in the end the
real question is what is this movie
about what's the plot no the plot is not
the characters when they use their
powers swap places with each other
that's a mechanic not the plot the
plot I don't know either the
Badd is doing baddy things and needs to
be stopped it's a very simple ass plot
it's another High budget Grade B film
but it it lacks the camp and cheese
element that would make it a cult
classic 20 years from now but Aman
volani was really good in the movie she
has this infectious optimism you feel
like it's not the character that's
happened the time of her life she is
that doesn't always land with me it does
with her go forth and prosper kid you
were the best one in this film the rest
of the movie feels like an exercise and
complacency an attestment to the fact
that the MCU needs to take a break like
take a couple years make people miss you
regroup group reassess re-evaluate come
back in a couple years and crush it
don't give us more of this I say that
because this is generally speaking what
they give now movies that you're not
going to remember in T minus one day
yeah how the did we get here it's
under 2 hours that's nice yeah there's a
mid credit scene go ahead and stay for
that so you can see more bad CGI I heard
there's a post credit scene but it
sounds pretty useless to me okay the
Marvels have you seen it what did you
think about it what's your least
favorite MCU movie or MCU villain
whatever they are whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
woof